if you quit on something too soon that
you still love you will regret it for
the rest of your life if you don't love
it anymore quit move on you will never
win doing work that you hate but if you
love it you love it and you move on to
something else you will look back on
this day and regret it for the rest of
your life that you did not see it
through most people spend their entire
life living with regrets don't let that
be you the hardest decision I ever had
to make in my life was being an
entrepreneur I struggled a lot with the
decision do I want to be an entrepreneur
and had this opportunity to make 300 a
month and earn 30 of a company versus
going to work at a job that I thought I
wanted a job that I've been preparing
myself for that this is what I wanted to
do was in my high school yearbook of
this is where I was going to be and here
it was earning six figures traveling
around the world doing the investment
banking I thought I wanted to do and the
thing that allowed me to push through
and be an entrepreneur was me saying I
don't want to live with regret that I
would rather no one fail than not know
and I gave myself a I said I'm going to
give myself a year to do this and so I
decided to go for it and we struggled
and it was hard but I never ended up
having to go back and get another job
and ask yourself which decision will I
regret more if I don't do and then go
take that action I became an
entrepreneur because I didn't want to
regret not having at least tried and a
great moment in my life came a number of
years later but one of the people I went
to University with came back and said
Evan I went down that path I became the
investment banker and I hate my life how
do I become an entrepreneur and I looked
in his eyes and I saw the desperation
and the sadness and helped him but also
was so grateful that that wasn't me
because it could have been knee
motivation what's the thing with believe
Nation hey it's Nina Carmichael we made
this video it's because you're probably
the most ambitious person in your circle
but you know you're capable of more and
you get that Push by surrender yourself
with the best so today let's learn from
one of the best my husband Evan
Carmichael and his top 10 rules for
Success enjoy
rule number two believe what's the
difference between you and Jack Ma you
both have crazy dreams you both started
with the odds stacked against you you
both started with very little resources
so what's the difference the difference
is that Jack kept believing in his
dreams and his ideas when most people
quit and give up so I actually think you
should be on a mission for life I'm not
a big believer in in five year goals or
ten year goals I think they can help but
I think if you have a five or ten year
goal you're actually thinking small
because you can't predict where you're
going to be in five or ten years just
like the person you were five or ten
years ago could not have designed the
life for where you're at right now not
if you're growing because the world's
changing too quickly and you're growing
and evolving so the ideas and goals that
you had five years ago may not even be
relevant anymore but the mission stays
the same my mission is belief right your
purpose comes from your pain so my my
mission is believe I want to support
entrepreneurs uh because I struggled so
much as an entrepreneur and I think it's
the world's biggest problem I think the
world's biggest problem is people don't
believe in themselves enough
I think any other problem that you come
up with should have already been solved
by now but the person who could solve
that cancer you know the woman who
should have solved cancer is an account
manager at McDonald's
because she never won she never tried
going to medical school or two she did
but she didn't believe in herself enough
to chase it down because everybody
around there is telling her that she's
crazy you should be crazy you're doing
something that's never been done before
you're on a mission right and so no
matter how many people I touch with with
all of my content all my channels every
video that I'm making every speaking gig
every city that I go to no matter how
many people I touch it's not going to be
enough
I think that's great I think you should
have a mission so big that you're never
going to actually accomplish it I think
of Ted Turner's father who when he made
a certain amount of money became a
millionaire or whatever the number was
he killed himself because he hit his
goal and and hitting your goal is
actually sad
and so Ted Turner decided that I'm going
to set a goal so big that I could never
hit it and that's way more where I'm
aligned I think you should have a
mission something so big that you can
never hit it some people think of that
as well it's two it's too big and so why
even try
and I think of that that starfish
example of the kids at the beach with
the starfish and he there's like a
million starfish on the beach and she's
throwing the starfish back in the water
so they can live and the guy walks by
and says
what are you doing you can't save all
the starfish and she says I know but I
can save that one and this one and that
one right and so each person that you
helped each step you take is is
beneficial it's helpful you never want
to actually hit the goal but you wake up
every day working your face off to try
to hit the goal right to hit that
mission and so that's belief for me and
I desperately hope that you find it for
you rule number three have a good
morning routine nobody wakes up every
day and says this is gonna be the
greatest day ever not to unlock not Evan
Carmichael not Tony Robbins nobody you
wake up and you're tired and you have
stuff in your eyes and you have lines on
your face from the pillows the
difference between successful people is
that they demand Excellence from
themselves to the habits and routines
that they do daily the problem is that
thinking that these people are different
that if you're not waking up with tons
of motivation ready to take on the day
that something is wrong with you the
only thing that's wrong with you is you
don't have the habits that set you up
for Success every single day and today I
want to change that so I have a 5S
morning routine that I go through every
single day that sets me up for Success
that demands Excellence I'm going to
share with you guys today the first s is
sing the fastest way to change your
state is to put on music the fastest way
to go from feeling low energy tired
bored into an energy of I am ready to go
is music
put on the song not that makes you feel
the current way that you're feeling this
is where most people mess up you put on
music for how you're currently feeling
if you're feeling really sad and low
energy you're going to put on really
mellow slow music what does that do it
keeps you in the same state that you're
in
it keeps you exactly where you are what
you want to do is put on the music for
how you want to feel and so I have a
playlist on my main Channel called the
believe playlist which is the songs that
I listen to these are the songs that I
listen to every day they may work for
you they may not work for you there's no
Perfect song for everybody this is a
perfect song for you and so build a
playlist of the songs that make you come
alive here's the criteria if this song
came on it would force you to start
moving if the song came on you find
yourself doing this if the song came on
you would get out of your chair and want
to move around doesn't mean you're gonna
dance like crazy doesn't mean you're
gonna start building out the lyrics that
may be you awesome but if you're a
little more introverted or don't like to
dance something that would make you move
something that would get you at least in
your chair doing this that's what I want
make a playlist and put that on is the
first thing that you do every single
morning it'll make a huge difference to
setting the tone changing your state and
giving you energy and momentum to start
the day s number two is Sun I like
getting outside I think there's
something about getting outside of your
home of your condo your apartment
getting outside getting some fresh air
just being out in nature makes a big
difference getting some getting some
vitamins on your face from the sun
outside but also signifying that you're
you're leaving your bedroom you're
leaving the condo the apartment the home
you're leaving what happened last night
and you're ready to go off and start the
day this is especially important if
you're working from home because it's
easy to have your you know office right
next to your bedroom or maybe your
office is your bedroom and carry that
bedroom energy that tired I just woke up
I want to stay in bed I want to sleep
energy into your work and you won't do
great things if that's the energy you're
carrying to your work so having some
kind of ritual that splits up sleeping
energy to I'm ready to go energy makes a
big difference and I find the easiest
way to do it is to get outside and get
some sun bonus points if you're in a
condo apartment to take the stairs
instead of the elevator s number three
is sore and this is the most important
thing for me if you only take one of the
five I think this is the the most
important one to take what is the thing
that makes you soar every day what's the
thing that makes you feel alive bold
confident what is that and put it into
your morning routine at some point in
your life you felt bold you felt
Unstoppable you felt confident it's
happened to everybody the problem is you
don't feel that way consistently every
day
you go through these bursts these
moments of man I could do such amazing
things but then the next day you wake up
and you're a different person you're
back to the I don't know if I can do it
I don't know who am I to go do this
crazy thing that's the problem
so whatever the thing is that makes you
feel like you can come alive that gives
you that boldness and confidence planet
with intention every single day into
your morning routine for me what I do is
I record a message on my phone to to
Instagram to my stories to I put it to
LinkedIn and Twitter right now I'm
putting it everywhere but I need to make
a message so I think of somebody that I
helped yesterday
I think of somebody who commented on a
video who I met in person who I coached
on my Instagram live somebody that I
helped yesterday and then I make a
message channeling that person I won't
say the person's name but I have them in
my head I need to remind myself that the
work that I do is important
it's easy to get lost in numbers it's
hard to imagine that two to three
hundred thousand people watched my
videos yesterday that's crazy it's a
wild number right it's wild it's hard to
like what does it even mean I don't know
I'm just sitting here talking to a
camera in my office and two to three
hundred thousand people are watching my
videos it's crazy I need to think down
to the actual person I need to think
about an individual that this matters to
somebody that the work I do really means
something to them and then I need to
record a message and share that helps me
soar and I do it every day
what is the thing for you what makes you
sore maybe it's watching the 254 series
that I put up every day maybe it's
watching the espresso videos like this
that I put up every day and some people
every day this is part of the morning
routine is watching an espresso video
and I'm humbled to be a part of your
morning routine for other people it
might be meditating that might be
watching a video or might be reading a
book listening to a podcast I don't care
what the thing is but you have felt bold
Unstoppable and confident at some point
in your life what led you to feeling
that way and then demanded of yourself
every day by putting it into your
morning routine the third s is sore it's
the most important one the fourth ask
for me is sweat
this is just about being healthy having
a healthy lifestyle and I want to do
something that makes me sweat so whether
it's a hit workout a cardio workout a
weights workout I put that into my daily
routine because I want to bust a sweat
and I want to stay healthy into my 40s
which is coming up and then into my 50s
and Beyond and then the last s for me is
scare I want to do something every day
that scares me what I'm doing right now
is I take a cold shower so after
sweating I need to have a shower they
want to show up to work all smelly and
so hop in the shower but right away
start turning the colder and colder and
colder and colder and colder and then
right at the very end I go all the way
cold and I freeze and even just thinking
of it right now
it sucks which is the best right you
want to do the thing that scares you
every day you're teaching yourself that
I do scary things so whatever is scary
for you whether it's taking a cold
shower whether it's making a phone call
whether it's sending an email making a
video and posting it doing scary things
teaching yourself getting that out of
the way wrapped in the beginning I find
really helps me rule number four raise
your standards you are
exactly where you are and if you love
where you are then keep with those
people but if you want more out of life
if you've got bigger dreams bigger
Ambitions then you're going to have to
let some of those takers go now I'm
pretty fortunate that I haven't had any
real takers in a long time in my life
but here's the thing it's easy to
recognize the people who are really
negative in your life and want to
eliminate them but then once you've done
that you'll still find that there's this
middle ground there's these people who
bring you energy who are amazing who
lift you up or Austin be around and
they're people who are negative that you
cut out of your life but then there's
that middle ground of people who they're
just okay
they're not bad they're not great it's
just okay and if you want to raise the
quality of your life if you want to
raise your standards you can't be
hanging around at least spending most of
your time with people who make you feel
just okay so I got back from an event
with Tony Robbins uh not that long ago I
think it was last year when I went with
my friend Mark draker and
Tony at the end of his events has he do
this fire walk and he lays out these you
know coals these hot burning coals
across the parking lot and you have to
walk walk over and he has you seen Cool
Moss Cool Moss and it gets you all
excited and amped up ready to cross the
walk and the idea is you're doing
something that you're afraid of you're
doing something that you're scared of
and to show yourself that you're capable
of doing difficult things Mark and I
decided to actually skip the firewalk
because we rushed home and I did the
real fire walk which was in my life
letting go of a number of people who
were just okay it wasn't that they were
bad or toxic or big takers from my life
it was just okay and I realized if I'm
spending all my time on things that are
just okay things people projects ideas
that are just okay that make you feel
just okay right it's good is the enemy
of great if it's really bad you're gonna
let it go but if it's good you just keep
it around and then suddenly the good
becomes your standard your good becomes
acceptable when did good become
acceptable that's what you need to draw
the line tendency the ideas that are
just good
I need to eliminate from my life the
people that are just good I need to
either eliminate or spend less time with
them to leave room for the things that
are great extraordinary excellent
raising your standards making you
believe more in yourself and your
capabilities
and so coming back from that event not
even it was on that day not even coming
back it was on that day I went back to
my Airbnb with Mark and and I let go of
multiple people in my life and not let
go and say you suck just basically
moving on and and that allowed me to
have a lot more momentum now now I had a
lot more free time that allowed me to
focus on things that would build me up
that would explode my growth forward and
it's been a crazy year it's been it's
been basically a year
November 2018 was when that happened so
now it's been almost a full year uh I
guess by the time this video comes out
it's been a full year wow it's crazy
it's been a full year since I have you
have to let go of the takers first and
then you have to start thinking about
other people around you just good are
your ideas just good and slowly start
getting rid of those ones the projects
the tasks look at your calendar what's
just good in your life and get rid of it
and leave room and focus on the things
that are extraordinary that fill you up
that build you up that make you feel
amazing because you deserve it and all
of your great work all of your great
activities all of your great momentum
your great impact is going to come on
the other side of doing amazing things
you will never create something amazing
when you're working on something good
when you feel good and definitely not
when you feel bad also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there I'm really introverted
it doesn't come across right but I am
I'm really introverted uh I don't talk
to people on the airplane next to me is
is Justin in the house
there's Justin so I sat next to Justin
on the airplane on the way down so you
should just tell it as a theoretical
example but I actually sat next to
somebody on the airplane Justin and he's
trying to make small talk and uh I
wasn't trying to be rude just I Small
Talk makes me anxious like it gives me
crazy anxiety and so I remember
everything he said I remember he woke up
at 4am to catch a 6 a.m flight to get in
at 2 A.M here with me he likes his
coffee decaf with one sugar and one
cream
[Music]
he has a black leather to me bag and so
like I remember all this stuff but we
didn't really talk like that's pretty
much all we talked about on this five
hour flight down from Newark to here
and so I I I'm just get super anxious
when doing small talk and networking uh
at the same time I'm scared to make
videos
so on my YouTube Channel right now have
you guys watched some of my videos on
YouTube okay decent all right
um I've got 6 000 videos recorded on my
YouTube channel
2 million subscribers 300 million views
all organic I'm the organic guy these
guys are Pros that paid ads I'm not
fantastic at that but organic I'm I'm
your guy
and I still get afraid to turn on the
camera and press record
6 000 videos later because because I
want to be an icon too and I want to get
my message out and every video that I
make I want to be the best I've ever
done
but I'm still afraid to go out and make
the content
being on stage always gives me crazy
anxiety
right uh I was speaking
a couple weeks ago in Whistler and the
speaker before me was David Goggins you
know David Goggins he's like the most
intense human alive crazy Navy SEAL
ninja uh and then the guy after me was
football player Peyton Manning
Peyton Manning was at so it's like David
Goggins me Peyton Manning
all right right like
right uh
and in all honesty last year when I
spoke at growth
I I had the biggest panic attack of my
life backstage it's 10 minutes before
going live there's this big wind up and
lead up and like could you bring me out
just bring me out I can't wait to go and
and my heart's going like crazy and uh
I just forgot how I was going to start
my presentation
right I just I just blank have you guys
had that happen where you like you're
about to get on a call or presentation
he just you had it all down you
practiced a thousand times but then you
just go blank
great that was me
just before about to come out and speak
to you know a couple thousand people it
was the first time I was gonna I met
Brendan so you know he invited me out we
connected to Ethan it's the first time I
met him he was doing an interview
backstage and they said hey I'm going to
end my interview because I want to make
sure that I'm watching your presentation
like oh my gosh come on really can't you
just like have a coffee or something
backstage but it's but it's great and
he's gonna give me feedback like oh my
God okay I'm ready for the feedback and
so I get on stage and do my thing but
just before that what got me over it was
I took a little peek behind the curtain
and I saw a bunch of you guys
and I reminded myself that I'm not here
for me
I'm here for you
right don't be so selfish
right yeah you can cut that up
it's not about me it's about the message
and so
the reason why and even this even this
lead up here I'm setting backstage
Ethan's like calming me down because my
heart's going crazy Brendan is talking
about all the genius ideas that I told
him backstage like oh my God Brandon
like the setup
oh I better deliver
and I tell you this because I've seen a
lot of people from the Arizona event I
got stopped a lot over the past couple
days and they said Heaven I loved your
your speeches it was amazing like oh
thank you did you start your channel
where is it it's like oh no I haven't
done it yet
like what that was how many months ago
you love my speech for what happened
and at the end of the day it's just fear
you can come up with a really logical
reason why you haven't posted yet but
really you're afraid that it's not
perfect you're afraid that nobody's
going to watch it you're afraid that
people are going to watch it you know
you're afraid you don't know the
technology you know the gear you know
the team you're just afraid afraid
afraid afraid and we cover it with the
reason why we can't do it right but
really it's just fear and so I wanted to
share my fear with you because you might
look at Dean and Brendan and all these
mentors that you have and they come on
stage and they just look amazing
he's like well I can never be like that
but at least for my story I'm always
scared
right like I'm always playing anxious
and nervous I think if you don't have
anything that makes you anxious or
nervous in your life then you hate your
life
right because then you're just staying
inside your comfort zone you know
exactly what to do you're photocoping
your life over and over and over again
and so life isn't about having no fears
it's about conquering the fears what
what Dean said yesterday about having
the courage to jump out of the
helicopter right to be like on the edge
you hear the helicopter of the plane and
say I'm going to jump to have the
courage to do that that's what you guys
need to do and why I share it is because
the biggest reason why you guys aren't
taking the action on the most logical
opportunity the biggest opportunity in
front of your face right now is just
because of fear rule number six
celebrate yourself more your brain is
keeping you afraid and preventing you
from achieving everything that you want
because your brain is practical it's
logical it only understands a world that
currently exists and if you want to
change the world and you don't learn how
to hack your brain you are going to play
scared for life so I was trying to think
about as I was watching this video what
the when was the last time that I felt
really overwhelmingly scared like I
might not be able to do this I can't do
this I'm not keep capable I'm not worthy
I don't think I I'm gonna deliver a good
job
and the the only idea that came to mind
recently of a big thing was when I was
speaking at the event in Phoenix and I
was invited by Brandon burchard and Dean
grazioc and I was speaking of their van
and before me was Eric Thomas on day one
and I was the last speaker on the last
day and I remember the day of I was
pacing backstage about an hour 45
minutes before the actual event I'm I'm
there I'm pacing I'm walking back and
forth Brandon burchard said he's gonna
watch my entire speech and give me
feedback after which only adds to the
pressure and there was a moment where I
blanked out there was a moment maybe 10
minutes before I went on stage I'm
standing backstage and I blank out I
blank like I don't I don't even know
what I'm gonna talk what am I going to
talk about right now I don't even know
what I'm gonna talk about right now it's
been a long time since I felt that level
of
desperation insecurity overwhelm because
usually as soon as something as soon as
I hear myself saying this is hard this
is difficult uh okay let's go do it the
challenge in this situation was I
couldn't just get up on stage whenever I
wanted
and so I'm I'm left sitting there
walking backstage thinking oh my God oh
my God oh my God what if I don't win
what if I don't what if I don't give a
great performance what if I let
everybody down which is my greatest fear
what if I let the audience down and
Brendan Down a Dean down and I totally I
just forgot what I'm gonna say how do I
even start my presentation I'm gonna
wake I'm gonna I'm gonna get up on stage
and just face plant
it was this
I don't know minute of just real
desperation
of feeling like oh my gosh I'm gonna get
up there and suck
I don't know what I'm gonna say
and then the thing that caught me
so grateful that it takes like the
training the training this is how you
train yourself the training came in
I said what are you doing you're Evan
Carmichael
let's go
and that may sound super egotistical
but I think I think the self-criticism
only works when it's based off a
foundation of self-love like I think you
need to celebrate yourself more I think
you need to recognize yourself more not
bragging on social media that you did
some fake goal that you know didn't take
a lot of work but you might get some
accolades for from your friends and
people following you I'm talking about
what do you tell yourself like when you
walk past yourself in the mirror do you
see a rock star do you see a stud do you
see somebody who's gonna go change the
world most people is no and it's and if
it's a yes it's not consistent and so I
think doing the work to tell yourself
that you're amazing I think that should
be a default answer every time you're
nervous is to say I'm feeling your name
I'm you your name right
I'm Evan Carmichael let's go
and that motivated me to then instantly
remember what the thing was it wasn't
that I forgot what I was going to say I
was just too stressed out and blocked
that I couldn't actually get through to
what I was supposed to go out and talk
about and so that shift in my state
um by telling myself I'm Evan Carmichael
let's go
allowed me to connect to it and then go
off and deliver
um at least what I thought was a pretty
great speech and event who number seven
Focus you haven't said that this is the
thing this is what I have to accomplish
today this is the mission that I am on
and nothing is going to stop me if you
don't learn the focus on what's
important to you you'll never do
important things and live your life
reacting to what's important to other
people instead so I recently started a
new business with one of my thought
Leadership Academy students Jeremy he
came to my event last year I was
thinking about him on my tour this year
and said I want to start a business with
Jeremy around YouTube Consulting I get
asked a lot hey Evan can you check out
my channel hey Evan can I work with you
hey Evan can I hire you for XYZ looking
at my channel giving me ideas mentoring
guiding me and it's just not the
business that I want to be in but it is
a business and so I thought Jeremy
Jeremy's gonna come on board he's going
to do it now when I recruited him and
called him he was not a YouTube expert
and I gave him the homework and said
listen if you want to do this business
together it's got to be important to you
I'm halfway through my trip on my tour
I'm coming back in a month and a half
here's what I need you to know by the
end of the month and a half and I gave
him resources I gave him videos I gave
him insights and analytics and said you
need to know all of this know all of
this and then when I come back if you're
ready we'll start the business
and he did he focused he made it his
priority he knew nothing about this and
all of a sudden he became an expert by
every day all day long grinding to learn
by researching everybody who is an
expert at this understanding their
methodologies their best practices
looking through all my videos my
thumbnails my strategies all the things
that I've talked about in the past
digesting it kind of like the Matrix
when Neo is in The Matrix and and he now
he can learn Kung Fu and now he learns
how to fly a helicopter all of that
stuff that's basically what he did
and when it came back in a month and a
half
I put him to the test and said hey let's
do two free calls we'll take two people
from my community and say hey free free
call let's go and he blew me away with
how much he knew because he focused on
it he was a guy he went from knowing
almost zero
to now being an expert
to be able to really help give value to
people
and now when we're looking at new people
coming in
I barely have to do anything
because he already knows what I'm gonna
say he already knows he's already done
the work he's done the research because
he spent that time on focused effort and
this is where I think a lot of people
feel like they're never going to win
because you may not have had the
expertise you don't have the education
it doesn't take long to become an expert
it's just focused work that you're
passionate about
focused work you could quickly become in
a matter of months and expert at
something if you just focus in on it and
dedicate your life to that thing
that you love you can easily pass people
who are experts at something who don't
love their thing
but because you're willing to take it on
you're willing to absorb think about
when you went to school how much of the
information you had in your head but you
had to read over the page four times
so if you're at the same page four or
five six times because you got lost you
got distracted that's not focused work
because you don't love that thing rule
number eight stop hiding if I can't tell
the difference between you and all of
your competitors then the only reason
why I'm gonna buy from you is because
you have a cheaper price you don't want
to win on being the cheapest you're
amazing you're a genius you have Michael
Jordan level talent and it's time for
the world to see it you need to stop
hiding so remember not too long ago I
was in New York and I was meeting with
uh four more mentor of mine former
mentor of mine four more former Mentor
well that's hard to say three times fast
former Mentor former Mentor former
Mentor okay got it yes meeting with a
former mentor of mine and he was asking
what my competitive Advantage was and I
said believe
say believe what is that like believe I
want people to believe I want to give
people hope I want I want people to have
hope that it's possible and show them
another way it's like hope you can't be
in the Hope business you're selling hope
what is that you're never gonna win off
a hope you can't win off a belief that's
just silly and you know a younger
version of me would have felt man I
don't know maybe he's right here's this
guy who's had so much experience and
done so many things who am I to to judge
I don't know I've never done this before
but the me who was listening to him was
like this guy just doesn't get it I'm
gonna Crush I feel I already am I
already am crutches off bullied people
stop me and say hey you're the believe
God yeah that's my mission yo that's
what I'm doing every day that's what I
wake up trying to spread it's the
world's biggest problem and I'm tackling
it I'm gonna make my dent in the
universe Steve right I'm gonna go make
my dent in the universe
that's my competitive advantage
and there may be people who don't
understand it and that's okay you can't
let their limited view of the world and
and super limited view of you prevent
you from going off and doing your thing
rule number nine learn how to close
people think that closing is a bad word
that sales people are slimy and closing
someone on something is good for you but
not necessarily good for them now some
people are like that but it doesn't have
to be you you want to help people and if
you know that they should be taking
action in an area where they are not
their ability to follow through and
listen to your advice is directly in
relation to your ability to close them
if you want to help people you need to
learn how to close I was really in this
same camp you know I I thought sales
people were slimy
um I'm I'm a humble Canadian with humble
parents and never really learned about
sales and techniques and closing because
that's what bad people do you
and my my passion is to live a life of
service and I saw my mom do it you know
she's on the wall behind me and all the
great efforts that she went through to
help help humanity and the people around
her and there was a moment in time I
realized that there was this one moment
that this is when I needed to learn how
to get better at closing this is when I
realized I need to I need to learn this
skill because if I don't it's going to
limit my impact that I want to build
that I want to help people right it's
going to live my impact so here's what
happened there's an entrepreneur friend
of mine he had this successful business
that he was thinking do I sell it or do
I just let it run on autopilot sell it
or let it run on autopilot because he
wanted to go off and do something else
he wanted to leave the country join a
different business start something new
and this company that he created he was
on the fence whether he should just let
it go and sell it or go off and try to
bring somebody on who just run it and he
could be on autopilot mode
the the Allure of passive income and
just everything is going to be done for
you automatically right
anyway so I told them you need to sell
the business sell it now sell it while
you still have one foot in the water
sell it while you still have some kind
of care for the company before you hate
it because once you're moving on and
doing other things any any involvement
in this business is going to be such a
drain in the drag for you you can't be
in this thing you need to move on and he
hemmed in Hogs I wasn't sure and I I
wasn't good at closing him I wasn't I
wasn't a good enough Communicator to
help him through that decision because I
knew that was the right thing for him
anyway he didn't do it he didn't sell
the business he thought he's going to
live this life you know live overseas
and have this business run on autopilot
and then the business crashed
the business crashed because the
personality brought in didn't care as
much as he did wasn't the owner like he
was he wasn't there to make sure things
happened when crisis you know did happen
he wasn't super responsive and
eventually the business just fumbled
just just disintegrated just fell apart
even telling a story now brings me back
because
I see that as my responsibility because
he could have sold it and got a good
price it may not have been the price
that he wanted but it's way better than
just watching his business slowly tank
over time and I knew it was the best
answer for him and I didn't push hard
enough I didn't close him that this is
what he needed to do now you may be
watching saying well that's it's not
your responsibility it's his
responsibility you know he should have
known better you can only do so much and
yes at the end of the day I can't only
do so much and it's up to him to be able
to make that decision but I could have
done better right I could have done
better
I did not do my best because I didn't
know how to close I didn't learn the
skills
and as a result you know somebody close
to me suffered
and so I decided that I needed to get
better at it I needed to learn more I
needed to improve myself so that with
every entrepreneur that I meet I'm a
little bit better I'm A Little Bit
Stronger I can guide them just a little
bit better and if that my Improvement in
helping close them means that they have
a massive success because they decided
to take that path instead of going down
the wrong one because they were afraid
or greedy or whatever other reason
that's amazing
and if you want to influence people it's
the same thing if you want to help
people not just sell your product that
benefits you and doesn't benefit them
I'm not talking about using it for for
nefarious purposes right you want to
help people you have to learn to close
them
through through care through heart
through effort through energy
you have to learn how to close them and
Rule Number 10 the last one before our
very special bonus clip is have fun are
you enjoying Evan
Evan huh do you enjoying lying down on
the beach
foreign
[Music]
you look very comfortable
yeah
try to do what I gotta do
you gotta do what I gotta do how we
doing Evan
good how are you doing
I'm great I'm great Nina wants to do
this how often
a lot a lot like a lot means like once
every three years no once a week wow
once a week
I'm getting stuff done let's go I like
the Heat
the heat is nice and listen there's heat
anywhere Nina goes
water's cold the water is cold Evan
holder than expected yeah
look who we bump into
yeah
Nina got bored so we left Tina got bored
to be left because I could have napped
it got bored that was fine you might got
four until he left I just want to go for
a walk I just want to go for a walk at
the beach
nice
[Music]
if you're not happy right now it's
probably because you're not growing
humans want to grow we want to learn we
want to improve we want to get better we
want to feel like we're making
meaningful progress somewhere and when
we feel like we're learning and growing
and the work that we do matters we feel
great right if you feel great when you
learn the new skill when you when you
help somebody out when you felt that the
work you were doing was meaningful it
felt amazing
but if you have too many days in a row
where you feel like it's too hard it's
too big you're not growing you're not
learning there's
there's no hope
that leads down I really dangerous and
negative path not where we want to be
and part of why we become entrepreneurs
is because we want to grow right because
we're we don't want to have a crappy
boring job working for somebody else
wasting our talents away I remember my
my I didn't have that many jobs I had a
landscaping job which was super boring
just every day just rolling out of grass
and then I had a data entry job
where this really turned me off of the
corporate world where
I was doing the work of
we had six people five people on my team
and I was doing more work than all of
the others combined
and I didn't take lunch breaks I just I
just kept working and my boss wasn't
happy that because I was overhead
lighting gave me headaches I used to
have to bring in some snacks like food
or popcorn or carrots or something so I
didn't get crazy headaches and my boss
didn't like that I was eating a snack
while I was working
and I got in the trouble and almost got
fired
even though I was doing more work than
my entire team combined and it just
really
turned me off of the corporate world to
realize hey this is
this doesn't make any sense
I wasn't growing
you know I wasn't learning
I wasn't improving
and so you can examine your own life
if you feel like you're in a rut
chances are you haven't learned anything
recently
and so we can we can plan for this you
know you can change your schedule so
that you can focus on learning you can
put it into your daily calendar and
this is where I think it becomes the
greatest benefit my greatest tactic or
strategy for you
for myself
is schedule in learning schedule in
growing
so for me it's my own videos you know I
make these videos
hopefully for you that you learn and
improve and something Sparks for you but
I'm making for me I'm making for me
because I need it because I need to be
around people who are doing big things
and that I know that every day there's a
video for me amen it's it's going to be
positive it's going to be uplifting it's
going to spread believe it's going to be
motivational or inspiring it's going to
be Tactical
and I know that on my channel I'm going
to get content that I want and so I've
hired a whole team and built the whole
business basically around making content
that I want to watch and thankfully
enough of you guys want to watch it as
well that it it I can build a business
and have a team
but if I didn't or nobody else cared
about it I would still do it for me you
know it may not be as fancy I mean I
have as much intros and all that stuff
but I would still have it for me because
I need it and so
we tend to catch these things too late
because it's not part of our habits and
routines so if you notice you go to an
event or you watch a video and you get
all inspired and you're you got energy
and you're working and things are
amazing cool and then
have weeks or months gone by and you
realize what happened to me what how did
I fall off the horse
so quickly where did my energy go has
that happened to you
chances are is because it wasn't
scheduled
you know part of the entrepreneur roller
coaster is because we're bouncing from
one high to the next
without having any scheduled in learning
and growth
and so
my challenge to you would be to try to
figure out how can we schedule in
learning and growing every day
and so it starts with figuring out okay
what medium do you like the most you
know for me I like videos I like being
able to see stuff it just makes it so
much easier for me I'm a visual learner
before YouTube was a thing I learned
from books
that was the best thing available at the
time now I still have a habit of reading
10 pages at least a night but I don't
get most of my learning from books I get
most of my learning from videos
but for you maybe it's videos if you're
watching this maybe it's books maybe
it's podcasts
something like where do you get the best
learning and then the great thing about
where we are right now is there's so
much content there's so many people to
learn from there's so many people
creating
things out there that you can go and
learn from them
you know if I look at in Eric Thomas or
an Oprah Winfrey they have a similar
message just a different delivery style
and so whatever you want to learn
chances are somebody's already making
content on it
and so just go and find them and think
about who you're following right now
like do an audit of who you follow right
now we've fallen on YouTube we've fallen
on Instagram or Tick Tock or what
podcast you listen to or what books are
you picking up
and how many of those people that you're
following are subscribed to actually
make you feel
ambitious and hopeful and better about
yourself and give you strategies and
light you up and feel like you're
learning and growing right that's the
whole point of this we're trying to make
growing and learning a consistent habit
so how many people that you're following
actually make you want to learn and grow
and how many of them are you just
mindlessly scrolling through you know
when you load your Instagram or your
YouTube when you're just scrolling and
scrolling and scrolling and two hours
have gone by and
not only have you not learned anything
you feel worse about your life because
now you haven't been productive
you know you just kind of mindlessly
entertained yourself but it wasn't even
that entertaining you're like what just
happened to the past two hours of my
life has that happened to you cool
unfollow those people
it's not that they're bad people
because that content doesn't light you
up
and then start to be around the people
who do
and the easiest way is through content
so if it's my channel hey good news we
got content every single day for you
you'll never run out of having Chronicle
content to watch but it could be
somebody else is somebody else in
marketing their business or
entrepreneurship or person development
or whatever category you're in
to subscribe to those people and be
around them as much as possible and
watch your videos every day schedule it
in for me I go for a walk every morning
call it my believe walk I just like
getting some sun on my face and fresh
air and getting out of the home and it
just gives me some perspective and a
little bit of motion and helps me set up
my day and then I'll I'll have a video
going
from my channel
and um every morning will be somebody
else it'll be
Elon Musk or Oprah Winfrey or Mel
Robbins or Tony Robbins or garyvee or
Tom Billy or whatever and that's what we
do is pull the best clips that I would
learn from and then we share with
everybody else but that's a part of my
daily routines and I've I've seen my own
growth and development and learning and
bravery and courage and momentum and
consistency
be directly contributed and correlated
to
the content that I'm consuming daily
and so step one is to unfollow and
unsubscribe from the people who just
make you waste time feel worse about
yourself get Envy
or just mindlessly tune out
and step two then is to figure out
I need to make learning you need to make
learning growing a part of your daily
habit and so where in your calendar can
that fit
if it's over breakfast if it's a morning
walk if it's a afternoon lunch like
where in your calendar can you put
learning from your preferred Style video
podcast books Etc learning into your
daily calendar if you did that your life
will change if you did that every day
for the next year every day if you did
that if you scheduled that in and you
actually did it and you you watch your
video write a book or listen to podcasts
that inspired you said you know what I
can do this I can do more I can be more
I can accomplish This I Gotta stop
thinking small and stop doubting myself
and stop telling myself that I suck and
I can't do it I can't do this like if
you felt that energy every day from
watching a piece of content that you
intentionally put into your habits
routine every day for the next year
your life will totally transform
you will be a totally different person
which then allows you to serve more to
help more to make more money to guide
more to be a leader more all of it all
of your Ambitions and dreams everything
that you want
is all possible
but you have to factor learning and
growing into your daily consistent
habits and routine focus on one idea and
make it work focus on one business model
focus on one Revenue stream focus on one
social media Network and make it work so
many times we're focused on too many
things we're distracted and our
entrepreneur ADHD kicks in and as a
result nothing happens for all the
people who are telling you to have 13
different passive income streams because
if one goes away you still have all
these other 12 most people who start off
doing that make zero money from all of
the passive income streams you're making
ten dollars a month four dollars a month
seven dollars a month where instead if
you could focus on one thing
and maximize it and make it amazing and
put your energy into it you will see
exponential results I look at social
media as an example and I just finished
this training where we did the seven day
build to serve challenge it was amazing
had so many awesome new thought leaders
coming to the program people have got a
big message want to serve and one of the
questions I kept getting asking is
how do I be on every social media
platform how do I be everywhere how do I
get started and just blow up everywhere
and it's like you don't right the answer
is don't don't don't try to do that
if you are the person right now who is
trying to be everywhere look at your
social media accounts
chances are you're sucking everywhere
chances are not not you suck as a human
just the results aren't there the
effort's not there the energy is not
there because you're so forcing yourself
to just get out there and create content
and be in all the platforms
that you also have a million other
things that you have to do and so as a
result you're you're creating
really mediocre content
content that people aren't interacting
with and if people don't like what
you're putting up it's not going to lead
to results for your business and so much
much much much much better it doesn't
mean that you can't be there you know
it doesn't mean that at some point you
can't be there that as you build your
brand and you get bigger and you hire a
team and you have more money that you
can start to do this but much better at
the beginning is to figure out
what is the one platform what is the one
Revenue stream what is the one business
model the one thing that if I focus on
that thing
it's going to lead to results so then I
can scale
entrepreneurs have a hard time with this
because we want to do so many things we
have our add brain going on and
we don't want to just do one thing we
also feel like it
is limiting for what we want to do right
we have a big Vision a big mission a
giant goal for what you want to
accomplish
doing just this one little piece of it
feels too small
the way that I would structure it and
think about it is this is just a
sequence
you still get to do everything
you still get to do it all
you just have to go in order you have to
create a sequence that the thing that
you need to focus on at the beginning of
your business whether it's your Revenue
stream whether to social media success
whatever it is what you have to figure
out is how do I start to as soon as
possible get a sustainable business for
myself
so that I can quit my job if you have
one so that I can bring income in for
myself my family so I can start to
afford to hire a team even if it's
part-time or one person so you can scale
up your company so that I can then go
off and do all the other things because
some of your ideas are are amazing and
huge and require more people and time
and effort and energy and some of the
ideas can get started a lot faster
and so if you want to go and accomplish
your big goal your big dream your big
mission then it's important to think
about the sequence of things that
instead of doing everything all at once
and as a result all of the results being
mediocre focus on the one thing that if
you push that lever you really maximize
that thing
you could start to make more money you
could start to have more impact you can
start to have more reach you can start
to see more success that then allows you
to bring on more people to help you
build and scale
for me we've got 37 people on the team
now
and
I can do so much more you know because
we got team then if it was just me by
myself doing everything and so in
building my mission I want to solve the
world's biggest problem right people
don't believe in themselves enough and
so in building that up I need people I
need help I need support I need team I
need I need a lot more than what I've
got right now
but and be able to build a business that
can bring in money then I can afford the
higher team that helps me accomplish a
lot more things and take on a lot more
projects but if I was at the very
beginning of what I was doing right now
I would not be doing most of the things
that I'm doing right now
I'd still be accomplishing and going
after the same mission
but I'd have to pick one thing to focus
on
I think the one thing at the beginning
that I think I could make some money
doing this so that I can live I can I
can pay you know rent mortgage
I can pay my internet bills I could pay
for some food not not living you know
fancy life but just being able to live
and survive so I don't have to have a
job and then I would start thinking okay
how do I then scale this one thing that
I'm working on
to build up to the point where I can
remove myself or at least take some of
the pieces off so that I can hire a team
to help build and scale and grow if I
look back at my YouTube Journey here I
did everything at the beginning you know
I I uh I filmed it I researched it I
edited it I did all of it and it took a
crazy amount of time and I made a lot of
mistakes and I did a lot of stuff that I
probably shouldn't have done and
just by focusing on that thing and
making content and creating videos it
then allowed me to make a little bit of
money but then I could hire my first
part-time editor that then turned into a
full-time editor that turned into a
second editor and a research person that
turned into someone helping with the
thumbnails and the graphics and it
continues to build up and scale but
everything I was doing myself in a
mediocre way but getting it done
to then be able to scale out a team and
so most people are just stuck doing too
many things you start like look at what
you're doing on a day-to-day basis look
at your calendar you have a limited
amount of time right you have a limited
amount of time there's only so much you
can do in in a day in a week you have
other responsibilities maybe you have a
job maybe you have family kids health
that you have to look after you know
there's a certain amount of time that
you have that you can dedicate to this
thing that time needs to go into the
right efforts
and again it's great to have that big
mission and big goal and big dream but
if you have a limited amount of time
every day or every week
and you are
trying to create 13 passive income
streams with that limited amount of time
no one of the streams ever gets enough
energy enough effort Enough of Your Mind
space enough of your creativity Enough
of Your Love to ever become anything
and so you're diversifying way too
quickly you're diversifying way too soon
and apply that for anything that you're
working on apply that to your your
business and the and the opportunities
that you're chasing the Partnerships
that you're looking at the things that
you're saying yes to the social media
networks that you're trying to be on
do yourself a favor
don't try to be everywhere not yet
right just understand there's a sequence
to things and you can make it so much
easier for yourself to have more impact
to make more money to have a bigger
influence to be more proud of yourself
to start getting more success and more
results and more momentum so much easier
if you just sequence it out
so that you don't have to do everything
all at once you don't have to feel the
the handcuffs and the Restriction of
saying well I don't want to do this one
thing for the rest of my life this is
where it gets
you know entrepreneur Ade kicks in right
and we don't want to be locked in I
don't want to do the same thing forever
well you don't you won't do it forever
that's not the point the point is not to
do this one thing forever that if you
took these 10 opportunities in front of
you
could do all 10. you could do all 10.
just not all 10 at the same time because
if you do all 10 at the same time none
of them are going to work out
and often it's a small opportunity that
can pay you more quickly
that can start to build the momentum for
you so if you have your list of your 10
opportunities in front of you 10 things
that you could do great look at what
order should I go in
so I can start making money and start
building momentum one last quick example
I looked at a lot of thought leaders a
lot of people have a message a lot of
people want to be speakers and authors
and coaches and influencers and
they've got big goals and big Ambitions
for what they want to create
when I'm helping someone like that
usually the first option is coaching
the best thing to do at the beginning is
coaching so we're going to dive into one
specific business model right if you can
look at let's say be a speaker
getting brand deals as an influencer
writing a book and coaching if we had
those are four opportunities in front of
you right let's say so what did I say
being a speaker getting paid to speak
getting paid to do brand deals getting
paid to be an author and selling books
um even selling courses your own
materials and training and Etc and
coaching
those are those are you know four or
five different business models that you
can go through perfect
at the beginning which one is the best
what should you focus on
be coaching
why
people don't like the idea of coaching
because you're trading your time for
money right I don't want to trade my
time for money okay
well what are you doing right now you
know you're at a job because if you're
at a job you're trading your time for
money
if you have unlimited time to figure
stuff out and you have you have a giant
bank account then you could do something
different but if you need to start to
make money to build this thing up then
yes you're trading your time for money
but it's a faster path to get you out of
your job and into your business
full-time
where everything else takes a lot more
time
speaking takes an incredible amount of
time if you want to if you want to be a
paid speaker and and get paid enough
that it's actually meaningful
it takes a lot of time for you to get
good at the skill as well as for you to
build up momentum and a name in the
industry you have to do a lot of free
speaking gigs before you ever get paid
to do it so if you have a horizon of
years awesome but I'd rather you start
get paid immediately while we work on
the speaking career you want to be an
author and get paid to have a book cool
you can go and sell publish a book right
now if you wanted to you can get it out
you'll make you know you can sell it to
your friends and family your your
audience you'll make a a few bucks but
it's not going to be anything meaningful
to get a paid deal or to have a
significant even if you're going
self-publishing to make a lot of money
off your book you have to have a big
audience
to get the deal with a publisher they
want you to have at least a hundred
thousand followers that's like your
starting point to get in so is that
achievable of course but now we're
looking at years as a horizon as opposed
to like this has to happen right away so
you're not getting paid right now off of
your book so if you're sitting there
thinking right in the book creating a
great manuscript creating a great how-to
guide it's not going to be the thing
that helps get you any kind of money
anytime soon and I want you to get paid
because most people quit too soon on
their ideas or they're trying to do a
million different things at once right
if you're trying to create a course
same thing you have to build up enough
momentum you spend so much time making a
course creating the content filming
videos or writing instruction manuals or
creating the PDFs or whatever your
course structure is it takes so long to
make the course
and then you have to go and Market the
course and people don't know who you are
yet you don't have a brand yet so could
it work absolutely will it pay you more
than coaching yes absolutely most likely
it's way more easy to leverage that than
coaching
but again the timeline is so long
and most people quit too soon on it
where if you were coaching you can you
can make money right away as long as you
have something that can actually help
people right if you're good at what you
do you know how to solve somebody's
problem you can make money as a coach
right away and yes you're trading your
time for money but it's better than
having a job and it also gets you closer
to your customers
at the very beginning that much I'm a
much bigger fan of selling a service
than a product because it gets you
closer to your customers you get to know
their problems you know their issues you
know what exactly they're struggling
with and you can help them solve it
which allows you to create a better book
a better course a better product because
you've worked with enough people through
the problem
and so
most entrepreneurs fall into the
category I want to do all of it great I
want to be a speaker I want to be an
author I want to create my course I want
to create my book I want to be a coach I
want to do all of it awesome you have a
limited amount of time every week
to work on all five of those things at
the same time means there's very little
progress how if that's you and you've
been writing your book how long you've
been writing your book for
like when is it going to come out what
year
how many speaking gigs have you done in
the past three months
right how much time has gone into your
course it's like we start and stop and
start and stop because we're tackling so
many different things because you want
to do it all and you want to have income
streams coming in like crazy and there's
nothing wrong with that it's amazing but
there's a sequence
there's an order
that if you can as soon as possible
inside of your purpose
start to make money start to build
momentum start to be able to bring on
team to help you it's so much easier you
can go so much further you can go so
much faster you can have so much less
stress
you can have such a big impact
that you just need to focus
you just need to focus
it's all possible your big dreams are
possible
go in order figure out the sequence that
will start to get you paid
Focus I think we play small by default I
think
man we are capable of so many amazing
things and we're constantly living in
fear and excuses and reasons why we
can't do something and we we have it
trained in US
from a young age our parents our family
our friends our teachers think about who
did you learn about life from probably
people who didn't like their own life
you know who did you learn about careers
from probably people who did not have a
great career you know who barely are
enjoying what they're doing in their
work and they're living in scarcity
mindset of this is all I can do and
that's what we've learned from and you
know guidance counselors at school do
they love what they're doing I mean I
think this is a huge problem and we're
stuck living small and living scared and
living as a result way below our
potential of what we could do and who we
could help
I I think it's a big problem I think
lack of belief is the world's number one
problem when I wake up every day trying
to do trying to help trying to create
and so how do you how do you get out of
it well I think the starting point is
being around the people who are living
and doing the things that you want to do
I think the way to 10x your results is
not to 10x your effort
sometimes it is especially at the very
beginning sometimes the answers just do
more work but once you're at your Max
Capacity you you get to a point where
you can't actually 10x your work anymore
it's changing your mindset it's getting
new leverages busting through limiting
beliefs because
just working harder will not be the
answer anymore right is it working
harder working smarter well it's both
right you have to working hard is is
your entry to the game
nobody went without working hard in
anything you have to work hard but
there's lots of people who work hard who
who never accomplish their goals who
don't end up succeeding or winning
because they're not working smart so
it's a it's always a mix of both and so
if you're not working hard then you
don't have a shot but assume when you
are working hard and you want a 10x
again then it's a shift in mindset and a
shift in living beliefs so how do you
identify the living beliefs how do you
figure out where it's holding you back
how do you break through the Paradigm
and hit a new level a lot of it is
environmental
the the current thinking that you have
was environmental it's your parents and
your family and your guidance counselor
and teachers and family Etc that's
environmental you've adopted their
beliefs in
and unfortunately a lot of them are
negative limiting beliefs there's
probably some that a lot that are very
positive but a lot of them you've
adopted that that actually don't serve
you anymore for what you're capable of
and where you want to go especially
what's possible now in today's
environment so the shift is in a new
environment to start to surround
yourself with the people who are like
the people who you want to be
who believe the thing that you want to
believe and whoever's more confident
wins and so if you're around people who
are deeply confident that the thing that
they're after is possible or they've
already gone and accomplished it if they
deeply believe it and you just kind of
don't believe it they'll pull you into
the land of belief because they they are
more confident in their belief than you
are in the disbelief and so it's finding
the people who are living the life that
you want or at least aggressively
chasing it down they will motivate you
inspire you to want to go and live your
life as well so well how do we do that
right I mean it'd be great to be able to
hang out with Warren Buffett and Elon
Musk and all these people every day but
you know we can't so how do you do it
well
step one I think is just through content
it's why I make so many videos on all of
my channels is why I've stayed
consistent over a decade of making
content why because
I think when you are around the people
even just visually even just through a
computer screen or a cell phone it
starts to shift your beliefs and your
mindset and what you can do even for me
I make these videos for myself so that I
can be around John Ashraf and Warren
buff and Elon Musk and Oprah Winfrey Etc
because they inspire me to want to be
bigger looking at Elon Musk is an
example the news of the day right now as
I'm recording this video is he's looking
at buying Twitter and when somebody
asked me yesterday on Instagram do I
think Elon Musk will buy Twitter
said no I don't think you'll buy Twitter
but it's probably not a good idea to
underestimate Elon Musk
in general right
you know lots of people have
underestimated him and he's proven them
wrong many many many times and I just
like the thinking
you know one of the things I love about
Elon Musk is
whenever I watch his stuff it challenges
me to think bigger
why would Elon Musk it logically if
you're thinking through it if you're if
you were running Tesla uh in SpaceX
would you have thought about buying
Twitter
would that enter the realm of
possibility you know like this is the
difference between
small thinking and expansive thinking
like in his world it makes sense
and he wants to have a backup plan for
the planet whenever I think I'm thinking
big
Elon Musk is trying to have a backup
plan for the entire planet I realize I'm
still thinking way too small and the
point of that is not
um to beat yourself down like oh I'm not
as big a thinker or as Elon Musk right A
lot of people say comparison is a thief
of joy and a lot of people will
get off of social media because they're
comparing themselves to others I think
comparison can be a fantastic tool I
think it can be amazing because when you
are
running with
people who only make you feel good about
yourself but based off of their smaller
accomplishments then you stay stuck and
you stay a big fish in a small pond I
think competition is amazing but using
it in a positive way as opposed to
looking at someone like Elon Musk and
saying oh he's so much smarter than me
he thinks so much bigger than me I suck
I'm never going to be able to do that
look at this hey this is what's possible
there's not that big a gap between you
and Elon Musk it shows that it's
possible that you could do it too if he
can do it then you can do it
you came from South Africa and
immigrated to Canada then immigrated to
the United States he had a father who he
calls a Monster who beat him he had his
friends bully him and push him
downstairs at school like he had
he had all sorts of pain and Trauma and
struggles
in his early life and he if he can
overcome that to get to where he's at I
see it as so can you and I see the
comparison as a opportunity that when
you see somebody else do something it
makes you feel a lot more confident that
you can do it too and so just use it in
a positive way instead of a negative way
so whenever I see someone like Elon Musk
it's a challenge to myself and looking
at him trying to buy Twitter it's like
huh what should I be doing you know it's
easy to get stuck in the same in the
same Groove but the groove can also be a
rut in that
you're getting slow growth and improving
where it could be a lot more expensive
it could be having exponential growth if
you change your environment to be around
the people who have expansive thinking
right so step one is just through
content through through aspirational
mentors what I call them an Elon Musk a
John Assaraf I Oprah Winfrey people who
who you
may never meet but you can still learn a
heck of a lot from
step two is to then try to go to some
events that change up your environment
right if we're a product of our
environment then if you're always stuck
in the same habit the same house the
same routine the same environment then
it's going to constrict the thinking
have you ever noticed when you go on
vacation you come up with some great
ideas why well you've changed your
environment you've been influenced by
new things and it leads to more
expensive thinking so doesn't mean you
have to go take a vacation to the beach
or something this week but but what are
some changes you can make to your
environment what are some conferences or
events you can go to to be around the
people who think the way that you want
to think to inject some newness some
creativity some ideas into you that will
have you come back a stronger Bolder
more courageous person because you've
broken some of the chains of the rut
that you were in that things that used
to make sense like yeah that that that
makes sense for me to keep doing all of
a sudden you go away to a vacation a
competence an event you come back to God
I wanna you ever gone away and come back
and wanted to be
a different person wanted to be working
on new projects new goals come up with
new ideas I get ideas all the time when
I'm traveling just think about if you're
just constantly stuck it doesn't mean
you have to go travel on vacation it may
mean you take up salsa dancing it may
mean you try a new hobby take that idea
that you've got and just go go to it
look at any events that are happening in
your city meetup groups conferences
clubs that you can join and be part of
to meet new people and take on a new
interest and I promise you they may not
all work out in terms of this is my next
career move but it leads somewhere it's
a part of who you are you take the
learnings and the lessons from that and
it'll make you a better person a better
entrepreneur and you'll find a creative
way to mix things together I think if
Steve Jobs who started Apple who dropped
out of University because he wasn't
enjoying the classes and he dropped in
on calligraphy classes drawing like text
and letters for fonts which made no
sense like why are you dropping out of
this really practical school and
material to then sit in on calligraphy
when are you ever going to use
calligraphy it made no sense but he was
interested in it and what ended up
happening was when he's when he started
the apple and he created the Macintosh
it had the most fonts it wasn't just
boring computer fonts there were a bunch
of different fonts that he could use uh
that people could then use in their word
processing Etc and it was the most
beautiful computer at the time with with
unique fonts why people because he
pulled from his experience in his
calligraphy classes and how he describes
it is you can't connect the dots looking
forwards only backwards he didn't know
going to the calligraphy class that you
know what in five years I'm going to
start a company and I'm going to have
beautiful fonts as a part of it he was
just interested in calligraphy so he he
went to the class not knowing how it
ever working out but trusting that the
dots would at some point align in the
future right so looking back it makes
sense oh this and this and this all the
line to get me to where I'm at
but he wouldn't have known that unless
he dropped out of school and dropped in
on the calligraphy class so it's
changing the environments being a part
of new things it's it's not just staying
stuck in the same habit the same
routines and and same thing you're doing
constantly and that will inject newness
that will then allow you to be more
creative and create amazing
opportunities for your next goals so
step one is to be around aspirational
mentors to be around the people like an
Elon Musk Oprah Winfrey Etc watching
videos content interviews podcasts books
that make you feel better stronger more
courageous step two is to get out of
your comfort zone and go go to things
physical things travel more take take on
classes say yes go to conferences and
events just so that you expose yourself
to new ideas and opportunities and come
up with fresher ideas of what you could
do with your life and step three is to
to actually have humans in your life who
you're around who make you want to push
and do more and be better and this mean
hey if you're hanging out with Elon Musk
amazing that's awesome you're probably
not doing that but who can you hang out
with who are on the same similar path as
you and that's where I love groups like
mover makers that I created for Thought
leaders but you know some Movie Maker is
something else but being around other
people who are doing the thing who
believe in this in the same thing if
you're if you're trying to run more join
our running club you're trying to work
out more you're going to join a gym if
you want to be a thought leader join
mover makers if you're like join a club
or a group where you can feel like
you're not doing this alone where you
can talk to people about the journey
that you're going on will they'll
understand you and not look at look at
you like you're some kind of alien like
your family or friends might like what
are you talking about what are you
getting into right join relevant Discord
groups like be a part of a community
because it's probably the biggest
mistake I made early on in my life I was
doing everything all by myself I had I
had business partners I guess but I felt
isolated felt alone I didn't have
friends had nobody to talk to and
I really really struggled so find other
people who are on this journey that you
can do it with because when you feel
like you're doing it with other people
and you're not alone you'll be a lot
more productive a lot more effective and
have a lot more fun as well burnout is
real but I think most burnout happens
because people are not doing the thing
that they actually love doing it's not
just about being busy and keeping your
mind occupied all day you can be busy
and hate your life and get burnt out if
I was an accountant I would hate my life
and burn out in a day because I don't
like being an accountant but doing this
thing that I love I put in way more
effort way more work and I love it it's
been 10 plus years of still having my
YouTube channel and I'm not burnt out if
anything I'm pushing harder than ever
before because I love it and so I think
it's not just about being busy it's
about being busy on the thing that is
your mission for life now compassion
fatigue is a thing doing it so much that
you burn out yourself is possible but
again that is not why most people are
burning out most people I believe are
burning out because they're spending too
much time too much energy too much
effort doing things that they hate and
if you wake up and hate your life and
hate the job you're about to go to then
just no wonder why you feel like you're
burning out so I recently came back from
going to Tony Robbins event in Dallas he
invited me to sit in the front row and
uh super blessed and grateful to have
Tony support and I went there with Alex
friend of the channel who helps me run
trying to dance salsa and we're on a
super crunch timeline because Alex was
teaching classes the the evening before
we left and then the day of the last
event and we we rushed down there Alex
was flying in just to get to the event
he's late on the first day we're rushing
to leave on the last day and it's
non-stop if you if you've been to a Tony
Robbins event it's it's all day all
night it's eight in the morning to
midnight and then up again the next day
and doing the same thing and and it's
wild and it's fun it's amazing and my
favorite thing to do whenever I travel
is actually meet believe Nation meet you
guys and so all through the event I wear
my believe hoodie and I'm not wearing
Grand stuff I'm wearing Evan Carmichael
stuff with the plane and the believe on
the back and people are stopping me and
that's actually the best it doesn't take
away from my experience Tony's often on
stage at the top at the beginning every
event saying hey I have some friends of
mine you might know them don't be
celebrities leave them alone don't talk
to them let them have their own
experience and it always makes me sad
when he says that because for me meeting
you guys meeting people who recognize me
and that's a group that I over index
because people who watch Tony videos you
know they're probably going to find my
content I like it I like it more when
people come and say hi it adds to the
experience for me and then on the last
day before we rushed out to go to the
airport I set up a meet-up right I had
an hour open before having to get to the
airport so let's do a meet up let's do a
local Dallas Richardson Texas Meetup
right and and it could have spent the
time doing something else or sleeping in
or writing my book or doing anything
else but
it's not burnout from you like that
fuels me that gives me more energy I
love it hanging out with believe Nation
gives me more energy than it takes away
and I then took an Uber to get to my to
the airport and the guy who drove the
Uber was actually in the the Meetup in
Richardson's like I gotta leave early
because I got to start my job okay great
and then I book an Uber and there he is
a total fluke but amazing and so it's a
lot of work you know I was all day all
night not connecting with my team not
doing the things that I'm supposed to be
doing and I still make time to be with
people and and make a one hour meet up
because that hour was open and
it fuels me but if it was something that
I hated just that half an hour just 15
minutes I'd start to feel like I'm
burning out like I don't want to be here
this is terrible and so I think it's
really important that you're doing work
that you love that would be a burnout
for other people but not a burnout for
you because you love it so much so how
do you find it how do you find the work
that you love I got a three-step process
called who I how I'm going to talk about
it in depth in my next book but let's do
a super quick analysis here to help you
guys who might be struggling step number
one is who so you're who is your most
important core value what is your most
important core value as a human being
mine is believe it's a one word most
important value for me so when you
figure out what it is that you stand for
as a human you can then look at your
life and see where you're falling short
if you're unhappy with life it's because
you are living incongruently with your
most important core value so someone
whose core value is freedom as an
example
you can look at your life like are you
allowed to be free are you free at work
are you free in your relationships are
you free you know in these different
areas if not then you're not going to be
happy that's why you're not happy
because your boss doesn't allow you to
have freedom mine is believe so believe
has to be in everything that I touch if
there's a situation that's lacking
believe I'm not going to be happy with
it so that just gives you already an
indication of who you are and starts to
make sense of your life going backwards
and allows you to plan it better going
forward so it's one of the most
important exercises I think anybody can
do figure out what your who is who I how
step two is why so why is your purpose
your purpose comes in your pain your
purpose comes from the deepest darkest
most painful moment in your life
whatever that was your purpose is to
help other people who are currently
going through that thing whatever you
struggled with suffered with endured
felt like you never want to wish that on
your worst enemy never want to go back
and experience again that pain that's
what I'm talking about you want to help
other people who are currently going
through that pain because there's a lot
of people who are currently going
through that thing who you were X number
of years ago there's a lot of people who
are currently like that right now that's
who you want to help for Life that'll
never get old that's your purpose for
life I want to help entrepreneurs for
life I believe in entrepreneurs for life
because I struggled so much as an
entrepreneur and I want to make the path
a little bit easier for everybody else
so that's your why and you're who and
your why are constant they never change
your core values and your purpose are
for life and that's amazing the last
step is how who I how how is your
passion how is how you got out of the
pain that you're in so you struggled
with something how did you get out of it
you may not be fully out of it maybe
you're still on your journey out of it
but you're further ahead than you used
to be how did you get out of it did you
read books did you watch videos did you
meditate did you walk your dogs did you
listen to music like how did you get out
of it how did you get out of it and that
is a recipe that you can teach other
people how you got out of it was not
some random one-off situation you can
teach other people so I struggled a lot
with my business I felt worthless as a
human I wanted to quit I told my partner
that I quit how I got out of it was
modeling success I looked at Bill Gates
how he started Microsoft and I applied
those strategies to my business and we
started to see some success 20 years
later what am I doing still modeling
success right I want to learn from Grant
I want to learn from Steve I want to
learn from Kanye I want to learn from
these people it's why keep creating this
content how I got out of it was studying
success and now I teach other people how
to study success
right how you actually go about doing it
may change when I first started doing it
20 years ago is through books right now
it's through videos and in 10 years 20
years is going to be through VR and a
bunch of other technologies that I'm
sure are coming but
the how you got out is a teachable
recipe that you can give to other people
so if you're struggling with burnout
and you think it's because you don't
love the work that you're doing and you
know that you're destined for something
greater that you do have Michael Jordan
level talented something but you don't
know what it is and you want to figure
it out figure it out this is this is the
process this is the easiest process I
know of to get there figure out your who
your one where most important core value
figure out your why your purpose comes
in your pain and figure out your how
which is your passion how you got out of
it you can teach other people and that
will set you up for an amazing life with
hopefully very little burnout and
definitely a lot of purpose
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to watch another top 10 rules of
Evan Carmichael check out the video next
to me continue to believe I will see you
there who are you when you understand
what you're seeing the most important
core value is everything else becomes so
much easier so for me it's belief my
belief is my single most important core
value how does that help well with every
decision that I make